mon cerveau mon bureau me fatiguer les
dernières 24 heures on commence à
connaître ça tu sais ce phénomène de
loupe médiatique où pendant 24 heures tu
vas être mis en avant
demain ça ira mieux parce qu'il y aura
des hauts il ya des bas on va pas se
mentir il ya des jours où je me lève le
matin je serai à limite à trouver du
pétrole et puis il ya des jours où je
suis super motivé c'est la douleur
physique c'est une chose le fait de
perdre un oeil physiquement c'est une
chose la douleur la plus la plus dure
c'est celle qui est psychologique quoi
et voilà c'est ça qui est très compliqué
à la les seuls qui sont capables de me
comprendre quelque part c'est c'est les
autres mutilés du mouvement avec qui
j'ai des discussions où là on se
comprend sur ce qu'on vit les uns les
autres parce que c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de faire comprendre aux gens
de de perdre un oeil
qu'est ce que ça fait et surtout dans
les conditions dans lesquelles on l'a
perdu quoi hein c'est ça c'est surtout
ça qui est ca c'est vrai que j'ai
maintenant ils remettent je suis j'ai
failli remettre leur équipe et le récap
j'ai même pas vu de leur maître parce
que j'ai pas envie de revoir ces images
voilà j'ai pas envie de revoir voilà ça
c'est quelque part ces images sont
prépondérantes surtout face au au débat
actuel justement sur le fait de filmer
ou pas les policiers dans les
manifestations
on aurait toi tu retourneras toujours
dans les manifs je retournerai dans les
manifs jusqu'à tempère aussi est-ce que
tu as peur je pas peur j'ai pas peur
parce que le bailleur la peur n'évite
pas le danger
et quelque part on mesure la force d'un
homme au nom de fois qu'ils se relèvent
non pas au nombre de fois qu'il tombe et
aujourd'hui on s'est inscrit dans un
combat où on a des revendications qui je
pense ont juste le problème c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas entendus on met
plus l'accent sur des phénomènes de
violence ou sur des micro au phénomène
de gens qui gueulent des conneries dos à
des manifestations qui ne représente pas
l'ensemble des gens qui manifestent
aujourd'hui donc je pense que ce combat
est juste qu'il est important de pouvoir
manifester pour crier notre colère le
plus pacifiquement possible dans la rue
puisque le message de gilet jaune si
elle voulait juste c'est aujourd'hui
font quand même imaginer qu'on est dans
un pays qui s'appelle la france où on va
crever un oeil parce qu'on a réclamé
quoi le mieux vivre ce que vous vous
appelez le pouvoir d'achat mais moi le
pouvoir d'achat c'est mieux d'enquêter
ligne c'est une démocratie directe des
pressions possibles s'est arrêtée de
survivre essayer de vivre voilà qu'on
puisse aller à la fin du mois calmement
tranquillement parce que tu sais
aujourd'hui quand on voit tous les
phénomènes de société qui peuvent avoir
lieu en france sur des phénomènes de
racisme le fait du mieux vivre ensemble
ou pas si à un moment donné les gens
étaient moins intéressé par le fait de
pouvoir rentrer
leur frigo tu vois cette capacité à
devoir travailler trouver le système d
pour pouvoir bouffer à la fin du mois
peut-être qu'ils auraient un peu plus
autant de pouvoir ouvrir un livre de
s'intéresser aux gens ce qu tu es
d'aller aussi de s'intéresser à son
prochain de s'intéresser aux mecs de
banlieue il ya eu noël loi il ya eu noël
et quant à noël moi j'ai vu des
situations et je te le dis jérôme parce
que j'ai beaucoup pensé à toi aussi
il ya plein de gens qui m'ont dit cette
année voilà pas de cadeaux pour les
enfants ou bien qui ont fait des prêts
et crédits pour acheter des cadeaux à
leurs enfants parce que pouvait pas s'en
sortir et qu'ils voulaient absolument
leur faire plaisir et c'est vrai que ça
c'est des situations et aujourd'hui
jeudi des gilet jaune souvent ils
voulaient quoi et ils veulent quoi les
gilet jaune
ils veulent arrêter de dire à partir du
10 du mois et bah comment des voiries
les autres le problème c'est qu'on est
en nous on était au début du mouvement
au 15 du mois les ingénieurs en est à 8
du mois je sais pas ce que tu sais le
meilleur allié qu'on puisse avoir
paradoxalement c'est quand même le col
vide parce qu'il n'a fait que mettre en
exergue tout ce que nous réclame depuis
deux ans et là il n'y avait pas deux
milliards
il y avait aucun milliards de
disponibles mais maintenant faut se
rendre compte aujourd'hui qu'on rentre
dans un système où qu'est ce qu'on va
faire pour soigner parce qu'on entend de
mettre à sac le système de santé
français
moi je vous dis ça comme ça j'ai entendu
dire que les états unis un accouchement
ça coûte 30 mille dollars
bell n'a pas le pognon n'accouche à la
maison bien sûr donc voilà je fais
référence aux femmes parce que celles
qui sont le pion par ça mais c'est
important d'être ici c'est une question
à se poser est ce que ouais j'ai eu est
à vue et tu le sais j'ai toujours été
auprès de vous avec avec les gilet jaune
et je le dis tous les jours pratiquement
dans toutes mes émissions les gilet
jaune c'est 95 99 % des mecs comme toi
qui veulent juste essayé de sûr de vivre
et arrêter de survivre essayez voilà de
s'en sortir et est ce que t'as pas osant
le sentiment d'avoir été gangréné par
aussi des mecs qui venait des casseurs
qui venait aux manifs est qui et qui ont
qui ont tué le mouvement face à ces
matches là quand tu as le mouvement
aussi giraud wanda mental et le toit le
mouvement n'est pas mort mais j'espère
qu'ils voient là qu'il est toujours là
et qui va continuer à se battre parce
que les gilet jaune ils ont vraiment
fait bouger les choses
mais pour vous des liens illégaux et
bravo à vous les je ne sais pas si on a
fait bouger les choses
un moment donné on ne retient que le nom
des vainqueurs et à part prendre des
saloperies sur le coin de la gueule on
reçoit pas grand-chose la tendance et
les choses et bravo à vous mais je pense
que le combat est encore rude
aujourd'hui je tiens à rappeler je tiens
vraiment elle rappelé parce que c'est
pas ma petite voix face à l'ampleur des
médias parce que voilà vous êtes sur ce
plateau messieurs dames d'accord vous
avez aujourd'hui cette possibilité de
pouvoir avoir la parole de pouvoir vous
exprimer
essayez d'imaginer aujourd'hui la
frustration de personnes comme moi et
tant d'autres aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
complètement dépersonnaliser parce que
le problème du gilet jaune c'est
d'exister alors on existe et c'est un
bien grand mot quelque part mais c'est
pas exister dans le dans la forme de
notoriété vous savez le fait qu' on
prend monsieur paul qui pendant toute la
semaine aura beau c'est rentré chez lui
il n'aura vu personne eh ben le samedi
sur la manifestation il va voir des gens
qui lui ressemble et va pouvoir exister
l'espace de quatre ans avant de pouvoir
échanger avec des gens qui réservent et
bien un problème allait faire du bien
aussi moralement il faut juste vous
rappeler que le gilet jaune ce n'est pas
une idéologie politique c'est un
melting-pot de personnes françaises
d'origine étrangère transgénérationnel
transsexuels trans religion moi quand je
suis allé à l'hôpital
c'est simple j'ai reçu des cadeaux de
allah de dieu de confession juive de
bouddhistes ils sont venus me faire des
prières c'est un mélange de france est
diverse et variée
le couple veulent s'en sortir le couple
que j'ai le plus ami et je me permets de
le dire parce qu'il m'autorise à le dire
paye 18000 euros d'impôts par an sur le
revenu et sont tous les samedis sur la
manifestation
ce ne sont pas uniquement des cervidés
des gens qui profitent des acquis
sociaux parce que si on n'était que des
chômeurs je vous garantis que le samedi
on serait 9 millions dans la rue sauf
que on manifeste le samedi parce qu'on
est des travailleurs et qu'on n'a pas
nous la possibilité comme dans des
grosses entreprises d'avoir des caisses
de solidarité ou syndicales qui vont
permettre de rembourser une journée
perdue 2 80 euros par année à 1200 euros
par mois